welcome back to drew's news hour and we
are so happy to get some extra time with
our dear friend and the oprah daily
editor at large the one and only gayle
king
thank you thank you thank you
bursary of oh magazine it's it's the
25th anniversary of o's favorite things
of oprah's favorite things 25 years ago
somebody gave over a pair of pajamas i
still remem remember them red and white
gingham checked karen newberger was her
name she thought they were so cool and
so nice and she said i wish there was a
way to give this to the audience this is
what oprah always thinks that life is
always better when shared so that's how
it started this one pair of pajamas she
ended up doing something for the
audience it wasn't even called favorite
things but needless to say it went over
so well that she thought now maybe we
can make it bigger maybe we can find
more stuff and that's how it grew but it
started with one pair of pajamas because
she loves pajamas
that's how it started and this year
we're doing something different we're
focusing on small businesses and
businesses from people of color and
women's businesses because during the
pandemic
those businesses in particular were hit
very hard you are a game changer for
businesses in fact we have three items
today that you're going to share that
are on the list okay
all right let's start with this number
one the list goes it's 110 items it's
our biggest list and the the price point
ranges from 1250 which was this all the
way to over 2000 where it which is has a
great router the row is actually really
good
i wish someone would give me the rower
but the rower is really very nice so we
have a big range where i'll give you the
router if you get on the dating app
oh
stop it
i don't know because i really do want
that rower a little a little because of
that
because the rower gives you a full body
workout
but the thing is dating app could
potentially do as well
[Applause]
knew drew barrymore was this funny
but the thing the great thing about the
list it covers whether you're male
female black white you can find
something for everybody age range people
you like people you don't like there's
something there for them okay and as we
know that variety is the spice of life
and it is all here and we're gonna start
with henry mask we like this mask this
is a henry mask they're washable we like
the back story of the guy rich fresh is
his name he was homeless for a while he
and his brother developed this they were
uh designing clothes in la for
celebrities they put their talents but
what i like about this it's not smushed
up against your face no it's really
comfortable some masks i feel like there
are such giant gaps i'm like what are
you doing that i can everything can get
in there this feels
snug and not with the henry man oh i
love it for every mass sold one is
donated we like that yes
and the adult four pack is fifty dollars
and they have kids masks too okay what's
next this is the crayon case it's a mini
notepad eyeshadow palette look at this
so you're gonna have your shades of
greens
open up another color drew i didn't
realize that the color of the notepad
correspondent oh the beauty junkie and
me eight editions with eight different
shades every edition includes mattes
shimmers traditionals and this is 1250.
this is the most inexpensive thing on
the list and but this is
i think that's good
this is awesome i think that's good also
because um
a lot of the times when you want like
really interesting pigmented colors you
have to buy a palette that is like the
size of a suitcase yes this is great i
have one more thing i'm very excited
because i just gave a beauty tip for our
beauty week um that we did and i
happened to mention olive oil is
accessible in your kitchen you can
always throw it on your cuticles or on
your skin
um especially as we get dry my hands
like crack open with dryness mine too
mine too look look how dry my hands are
right now yeah olive oil i know it's
kind of embarrassing that's why i need
to get one of these this is the olive
oil pedicure collection from foot nanny
so this is what you get you get the
olive oil collection it comes with a
buffer a soaking salt socks cream and
scrub for 149 this is amazing so that's
gloria williams the foot nanny and
because it is a season of giving do you
have something you want to say to the
audience drew barrymore really do i get
to say it again
you're all going home with all
[Applause]
it's fun we're giving everybody the
opportunity
by sharing with you guys and following
in oprah's wisdom
about life is better when shared
oh thank you
king
obviously catch gail every morning on
cbs mornings and boy are we lucky to
follow her act and check out all of
oprah's favorite things on oprah daily
right now
[Music]
you